I will tell you very simply, we won the election.
Elections have consequences.
We have the Senate, we have the White House...
...and we have a phenomenal nominee, respected by all.
The American people have a right to have a say who the Supreme Court nominee is.
And that say occurs when they vote for United States senators...
...and when they vote for the President of the United States.
They're not gonna get that chance now because we're in the middle of an election already.
He panicked or he just looked at the stock market, one of the two...
...because guess what, a lot of people died.
And a lot more are gonna die unless he gets a lot smarter.
If we would have listened to you, the country would have been left wide open,...
...millions of people would have died, not 200,000 and one person is too much.
It's China's fault.
That should have never happened, they stopped it from going in,...
...but it was China's fault.
This guy will close down the whole country and destroy our country.
Our country is coming back incredibly well, setting records as it does it.
We don't need somebody to come in and say let's shut it down.
We handed him our booming economy, he blew it.
Proud Boys, stand back and stand by.
But I'll tell you what, I'll tell you what.
Somebody's got to do something about Antifa and the left...
...because this is not a right-wing problem, this is a left-wing...
This is a left-wing problem.
Antifa is an idea not an organization, not militia.